Ciao ecco a voi il nuovissimo video che parla di come, salutano le persone prima di riagganciare il telefono
mi è venuta questa idea, perché l'altro giorno ero in giro e ho sentito una ragazza odiosissima
che ha messo giù il telefono, penso al tipo in questo modo:
cia,cia,cia,cia! COSA ho detto? DEVO SUBITO FARCI UN VIDEO e infatti eccolo qui!
siete pronti?
tre....due....uno....via
ok cia, cia,cia, va bene
si mamma, va beneeee, ooookeeeei, si tranquilla, ciaooo, ciao, ciao.
allora, ci aggiorniamo, nel senso che io sento lui vedo cosa mi dice e ti aggiorno così rimaniamo aggiornate va bene?  dai dai
ti aggiorno cara, ci aggiorniamo.
dai metti giù tu,.... no prima tu
COSA? HAI AVUTO IL CORAGGIO DI RISPONDERE ALLA TUA EX? MI FAI SCHIFO.....
E ALLORA COSA C'è? IO BUTTO GIU' TUTTE LE VOLTE CHE VOGLIOOOOOO
Va bene dai top top top, favola sei pazzesca ci vediamo stasera... top top top top
Silvano ti fermo subito, sono in mezzo al traffico c'è il delirio,  guarda ti richiamo appena posso, ciao tesoro cia cia cia
Mamma non sento niente, dove sei? non sento...spostati dove sei in un tunnel?
NON SENTO!!!
Va bene carissima, salutami tutti salutami la Gigliola e il suo moroso, come si chiama quello li? Mario...brava
e le tose li...la Benedetta, la Sara tutte quante eh!
anche i cani!
Ciao Bibi, baci baci baci smak smak smak ciao baci baci baci
hi guys, se vi è piaciuto il video,  io penso che sia amazing,  miraccomando iscrivetevi al canale e commentate qui sotto e seguitemi su tutti gli atri social
facebook , instagram,  musically e snapchat
amazing,  buy guys!